we want to do is we want to look at
where it's increasing okay first so what
we're gonna do is we're going to scan
across the graph okay from left to right
so what we're really interested in here
okay are not the Y values but the X
values so when you scan across you can
see that the graph is going up okay for
this piece of the graph and it's also
going up to the right for this piece of
the graph so as the X values are
increasing the Y values are increasing
here and the Y values are increasing
here now when we write the intervals
again we want to think about going from
left to right or from low to high and so
here you can see this is going off
towards negative infinity so we have
negative infinity okay all the way up to
where X is negative 2 okay now when you
do the increasing and decreasing
intervals you want to make them open
intervals you you don't want to include
the endpoints that's where it's changing
direction it's changing from increasing
to decreasing or increasing to constant
so you always want these to be
parentheses not the square bracket where
it includes that point
okay so then also we can see that the
graph is going up to the right here when
X is greater than 1 okay so we're going
to put Union 1 to positive infinity
now we're students sometimes go off the
tracks is they'll start thinking about
the Y values so they might say well it's
increasing up until y equals negative 1
that's not correct you want to think
about you know what the X values are
okay and what the Y values tell you I
see the Y values are increasing see as
this graph is going up see the Y values
are increasing only when X is from
negative infinity to X is negative 2 so
these really represent the X values
where the Y values are increasing or the
graph is going up okay so this is the
increasing now you can see here it's
constant from X is negative 2 to X is
positive 1 so we're going to say
constant I'll just put a C there and
we're going to go from negative 2 to
positive 1 again notice we're using the
parenthesis the open interval it doesn't
include the endpoints whenever you do
these increasing decreasing and constant
intervals and then where is a graph
decreasing we can see no where is it
going down to the right so it's just
going to have these increasing and
constant intervals okay let's look at
example number 2
now this one we're looking at where it's
increasing so you can see it's going up
until you reach up right about there
okay and then it's going down until you
reach right about there and then it's
going back up okay so let's do the
increasing first so it's increasing from
negative infinity see this is going off
to the left so negative infinity up
until one two negative three okay so
from negative infinity to negative three
the graph is going up or increasing it's
also increasing from positive one
onward okay again we're looking from
left to right so what X is 1 to infinity
the graph is going up so we have 1 to
positive infinity are with me so far
okay so now where is it decreasing it's
decreasing from here to here now again
you don't want to make the mistake that
some students make they'll say oh it's
decreasing from positive to 2 like
negative 2 no those are the Y values you
want the X values so it's decreasing
from X as negative 2 all the way to X is
positive 1 that's where the graph is
going down so we're looking at this
interval right here so decreasing from
negative 2 to positive 1 and then
nowhere is the graph constant some
students might make the mistake and say
well it's constant for just a brief
second right there at the top there or
at the bottom there but only when you
see a horizontal line like this would
you write it as a constant interval so
I'll have a link to another video I did
just talking about interval notation in
general if you need to review that about
you know the square brackets and the
parentheses and you know all that so
I'll have a link for you for there and
subscribe to the channel check out some
of my past videos on Mario's math tutor
and YouTube channel and I look forward
to seeing in the future videos I'll talk
to you soon